your take on the Spy balloons which is
that like China or is it aliens
well I I don't know much about this
Bible is they shot one down in Canada
and Alaska right yeah right um do we
know what they look like well we know
that the one that was drifting over
South Carolina and all over the U.S was
a spy balloon but we don't know what
these other things were yeah you know um
because they weren't shaped like the
first one wow you know and and the
government was strangely silent for a
long time
Aliens send down [__] that they could
use gunned down you know what I mean
it's like it's like they're gonna
high-tech it's not high tech enough for
me yeah I mean yeah I don't think I
don't think it's aliens yeah you know
what I mean don't do or anybody I don't
know I just hope you get to do the stop
human hate the PSA gets alien or it's
just Daniel and everyone else or stop
aliens yeah but you know I learned let
me say this I learned a valid lesson
today yeah and I honestly and you're
gonna not believe me but I'm saying
right now it I think I'm gonna do
something I don't know what it is yet
but I I want it because now I feel like
um I do have a voice and I do have my
opinion about it you know what I mean
and um and I do love my people that look
like me are you kidding Bob you have a
huge voice I mean look at the people who
you've had on your podcast look at the
number of listeners and Watchers you
have I do I'm done I'm not just pumping
you up it's it's true it is true yeah
you're right and um we all have fear I
mean that's a real that's a very first
of all right all right that's a very
real thing yeah yeah every one of us
who's spoken out about this issue has
gotten the worst threats online yeah all
of us and it sucks to read that stuff
and and go onto your feet and and hear
hate coming from the left and the right
by the way right it's both because
you're you're standing up for something
that you know 23 million of us
experience but we're only 10 of the
population so 90 of the population goes
I could give a [__] about that you know
or I don't know about that so you've got
to expect it but you know when I think
about that I think about people like
Martin Luther King Jr like what must he
have experienced when he was going
through what was happening in America in
the 50s and 60s I can imagine and he
ultimately gave his life for the cause
yeah now I'm not recommending that
everyone go out there I'm not doing that
but anyway give your life but I want to
live but at my point yeah but the thing
about Evolution I think is a really
important one because you think about
all the the people who have really made
positive change in our cultures and our
societies
Gandhi King Malcolm X Jesus Christ
what's the what's the thing that they
all have in common
they sacrifice they all gave their lives
yeah so that says take that how you will
you can look at that as a positive and
an egg or a negative but it's a fact it
is a fact yeah wow
let's switch gears
I'm curious uh when was the first time
you guys met do you remember that
interaction was that event
uh just in passing
do you have an idea I don't remember the
first time I just remember a general
sense of going oh I like that guy
yeah man yeah like he him I've had that
with grace to park
um I have had that with a lot of them